i'm not a fan of of uh
sort of binary assessments you know
college is bad
you don't need it you know college
everyone should go to well i think it
depends
um
um there are some people who are
extremely entrepreneurial who are
extremely disciplined to get the things
done they need to get done and may have
had a life experience that taught them
some things that have given them a leg
up at a younger age
they're the ones saying i didn't need
college so you don't need college that's
not entirely true
um to your point uh andronica i think
college provides more than simply
knowledge
i mean
am i using the knowledge from most of
the classes that i took in college
absolutely not completely useless
but what else did i get in college to
your point i learned how to learn i
learned
how to
pose an argument to question an
authority figure who has more education
than me in a constructive way
i learned how to debate i learned how to
disagree constructively
i learned how to fend for myself a
little bit you know grew up in a nice
home nuclear family and this was my
first experimentation with independence
you know when i didn't have somebody to
make me get out of bed in the morning
that would i actually show up to class
if i was fully responsible for myself
you know and i think it's like it's it's
like a halfway house between uh between
uh uh sort of nurture and adulting
um uh and there's much more to college
and i think one of the big ones is
interpersonal
where um you're you're learning how to
interact with other people who
don't look like you didn't come from
your neighborhood didn't go to your
school have a completely different
experience
and i think these are all fantastic
opportunities and you can screw up a lot
in college because it's like like i said
it's a half it's practice it's a halfway
house um
of course i think something needs to be
done for the the amount of money that it
costs and and to put yourself in debt
you know i think one of the big
complaints against my argument was like
why should i put myself in such debt for
for life experience
i concur
um you know something definitely needs
to be done for that but i i don't think
it's so so so binary college good
college bad i i think it it depends and
and i think there's more value to
college than than some of the some of
the
the trends that people are espousing
lately i think there's a lot of value
you